Four Seasons upgraded us though that's
sick yeah wait so did you do your
honeymoon right after or was like yeah
the family's still there no so the
family was there for like eight or like
eight days and then we had like four
days tour so oh nice what did you guys
do for that we just stayed in Florence
but we just booked a like kind of like a
random room with the Four Seasons like
yeah just chill whatever we get there
and they say we decided to upgrade you
I'm like sick they give us like they
only have like four of these sweets and
they gave us one of them the ceiling I
don't know if that's like an original
Fresco or they paid someone to do that
[ __ ] it was cool it was dope as hell
but I definitely felt like there were
ghosts or some other entities okay
I don't know how old that building is I
just started out like once the yo this
is sick wore off I just started
processing everything like yo this is
actually haunted yeah yeah and the door
is old as hell
it would close the weight of it would
drag it to close and it would do this
scary ass like
I was like yo don't ever open that door
we're not going to the bathroom the rest
of this trip all around 10 out of 10
nice stand out of things 10 out of 10.
yeah it was it was amazing are you jet
lagged no not now I could order [ __ ]
Popeye's Chicken right now and I'd be
good doesn't feel good to be back yeah
yeah let's talk [ __ ] about Europe
let's talk some [ __ ] no I was just
saying that like it's like a little bit
I don't know it's reassuring because
like when you see people's posts like
all summer long and they're in Italy and
they're on the whatever Amalfi Coast and
you're like [ __ ] that looks so sick I
walk past two of your friends and it hit
me after the fact what who
um I don't wanna I'll mention that okay
sure but I walked and I'm like that
couple looked mad familiar we went to
The Comedy Store with them like a long
time ago oh oh what yeah it hit me like
way after I was like two blocks down
random as [ __ ] and I was like oh whoa
you know what else is random
so this fool
this fool goes to uh Milan to see his
girl
and Kyle's there
what
he's just sitting in the land bro we
literally I'm just at this like you know
pretty park or whatever and we're like
hanging out I'm like recording a video
and in the back I'll have the video and
it's like you hear cash dude that's so
weird
that is so weird everyone's in Italy
right now
everyone that's what I'm saying yeah but
yeah sorry but yeah so like I don't know
it's just everything's so romanticized
and then when you're there it is [ __ ]
incredible it's amazing but you know if
you're a raise
in America or in North America at least
it's like you kind of like that feels
like home and so everything else there
feel starts to feel like a little bit
just foreign you know you're like [ __ ] I
can't wait to get home dude
by the last day I was so American yeah
Elaine and I were eating at pizza places
and we're like this ain't good pizza
you ever had Lou malnaties yeah yeah you
ever been to Chicago I just [ __ ]
bought yesterday you're gonna love this
this is the most me [ __ ] ever
one of my friends like posted on their
stories it was like a Portillo's and Lou
Malnati's collab it's a deep dish
Italian beef Pizza I thought it was
gonna be a deep dish pizza and it's all
Portillo's Hot Dogs in there
I could just bite
away at first
it's the other one [ __ ] out of those
what's like the Little Caesars one
that's not Lou Malnati's uh what do you
mean
um
in Chicago yeah God damn it it's the
other deep dish place it's like the one
that's like Lou Malnati's is kind of the
you know art art like artisanal handmade
it's Giordano's yes yes yes yeah yeah by
the end we're like this hey you care at
[ __ ] giordanos yeah blows this [ __ ]
out the water yeah so we're walking
around Florence and we see
the Melrose Avenue vintage store okay I
was blown away I'm like damn La really
reaches far away
but wait I wanted to get into this on
the wedding day real quick
um I need to get a haircut you know we
were the only day we were in the city
was Sunday everything's closed I need a
haircut my hair can't be that bad it's
gonna be pretty easy right let's find a
barber
until the wedding planner she's like yep
I got someone great I'm up I'm about to
get ready I'm gonna go the Barber's here
to cut you up I'm like dope I'm
expecting like you know someone who
looks like he's on a beard oil ad or
something you know tatted up early
mustache yeah
it is some dude and a woman
and they have a travel carry-on and they
just their presentation was like they
were traveling they didn't seem like
Barbers at all okay let alone
hairdressers okay so kind of look at
these two regular ass people and I'm
thinking why is there two so then they
pull up and they don't really speak
English and they're kind of just looking
around
and there's a stool in the bathroom and
I point to it and they say yeah great
okay
slide out sit down and they they kind of
look at me and gesture what do you want
I go oh [ __ ]
so I pull I took pictures how bad could
they possibly [ __ ] up your hair well not
much you can do to it right well so I'm
thinking how do I communicate I want a
zero fade oh right okay you know that
can go a lot of ways when you throw the
number zero out yeah
you know
no no no no no
zero yeah yeah
so I took pictures in advance and I show
them and they're kind of staring at my
fade a little too long in the picture
and I'm thinking oh boy they don't know
how to do this they're kind of just
throwing words out and I'm kind of
picking up pieces of the Italian I'm
able to translate it a little bit and
I'm trying to guide them and the guy
goes short
I say yeah and then he kind of makes
this gesture as if to like step I'm like
okay like he understands he turns to the
girl and he goes
go ahead my fear
when she grabs them [ __ ] Clippers and
does this dude
she goes two hands oh no she goes look
down I'm like
oh God
oh God and she just starts
with two hands
[Laughter]
and I'm bugging and I'm thinking you
brought your assistant yeah he's like
it's our first time yeah dude I'm
teaching her
oh the day of your wedding yes
she'd take a chunk out of your head I'm
sorry she's still learning yeah
dude she I can't like really she's like
she's like kind of cutting that she
pulls off and keeps like checking the
Clipper and I'm like
some of your skin yeah
so then you know that little lever that
kind of like moves the Clipper up and
down she keeps like fussing with that
okay and I'm like what
what are you doing you know I'm about to
take it from her and just tell them both
like hey I'll pay you just leave me
alone for an hour
she starts cutting
she starts here and she's like
and there's a point where it's just
going way too up and I go like I have to
cut and then she goes oh sorry
and then I'm kind of directing them on
how to cut it and they put it together
they don't [ __ ] it up that bad I asked
her to line me up she takes something
that's clearly a beard trimmer and just
starts kind of just like hitting the top
line and I'm just praying like please
don't [ __ ] it up please don't [ __ ] it up
I gotta be so funny dude little dude
so over a speed bump
I'm just looking like the inverse of a
of an iPhone yeah yeah yeah looking like
a Lego
yeah so they gave me a dynamic Island
just put some album art up there no
that's good it's chill
bro that's when the two-handed shakes
started happening oh no and I'm like
dude please please just don't do it if
you're not confident just leave it alone
but you know she she got it done shout
out to her her third time cutting hair
I'm glad you he's [ __ ] that's
confidence yeah that's high pressure on
a wedding yeah she felt no dude she like
I think she signed up for it okay
thinking that should be fine you know
and then when she got there and it got
time her hands were just and then in the
middle of the cut
the thing was battery powered but it was
one of those devices where you can't
charge it and use it at the same time
okay so she would like go to cut my hair
and go like
she's like
plug it back in get a like get another
strip in and it was just like dying and
her hands were getting clammy oh that's
the worst the razor like doesn't work as
well yeah and it like hurts yeah so then
the dude is kind of like they're both
doing the nervous laughter I'm thinking
dude just get this done please please